most of us know the Banshee as the
Whelan harbouring of death but where
does the legend originate from in Celtic
and Irish folklore the Banshee is a
fairy who scream is believed to be an
omen of death the Banshee screams served
as a warning that the imminent death of
a family member approaches it is
believed that each family had a banshee
of their own the banshees a spirit that
can appear in a host of different forms
the spirit is always female
but her age clothing and color of hair
can differ drastically the origins of
the Banshee can be traced all the way
back to the eighth century with the
first tales of women singing songs of
sorrow to mourn someone's death these
women were known as Keener's and often
accepted alcohol as payment this meant
that they were seen as sinners and were
often doomed to become banshees once
they had died banshees are often seen as
hateful and angry spirits however there
are some banshees who had a strong
connection with their family in life and
continued to watch over them in death
when these banshees manifests themselves
they often appear as beautiful and
enchanting women that sing songs of
concern and love for their families
these songs can be heard several days
before the death of a family member and
are often heard by the person whom the
songs concern the more common depiction
of a banshee is an angry spirit who in
life hated their families and this hate
is further amplified by death
these banshees do not sing a soothing
song their screams and howls are
chilling to the bone they do not appear
to warn a family member but rather to
celebrate the death of somebody they
despised in other Irish mythology
banshees are the ghost of a young girl
who suffered a brutal death it is said
that these banshees appear as an old
woman with rotten teeth and long
fingernails she wears rags and her eyes
are blood-red and filled with hate
looking directly into her eyes who cause
immediate death these banshees derive
pleasure from taking life and have been
known to actively seek out victims
banshees also appear in Scottish
folklore and there are some key
differences between those in the Irish
legends they are referred to as the bee
and knee otherwise known as the
washerwoman and they are also a symbol
of approaching death Libyan knee is not
doomed to be a banshee forever they will
only remain one until they reach the age
that they would have died in life as
they are not sentenced to mourn the
death of others forever it implies that
they are not born a fairy like the other
banshees in Irish mythology the B&E does
not weigh all like other banshees upon
the death of a person she would be seen
washing blood from funeral shrouds in
the nearby river it is believed that the
B&E was able to interact with humans
more than any other banshee if they
spoke with a human they would have to
answer three of her questions and in
return they would be able to ask three
of their own and be granted a wish for
anything they desired it is important to
note that the vast amount of banshees do
not bring death they are messengers
given families time to prepare for the
inevitable
if you've enjoyed this video then please
go ahead and leave it a like consider
subscribing if folklore mythology is
something that interests you
if you have anything you'd like to
discuss or have any ideas for future
videos then please go ahead and let me
know in the comments below as always
I've been your host mythology and
folklore explained